c'est il y avait une inscription à la
porte c'est un mac et salles de lecture
aux deux comme pour éloigner les curieux
cette salle ci n'a pas toujours eu pour
fonction de parler aux journalistes et
de parler au public loin de là c'était
un bar clandestin est a pas que le
destin n'est ce pas mais c'est un bar
aller jusqu'en 1976 les salicylés
première année servait de bord aux
députés il y avait une serveuse qui
étaient ici en permanence le parti
québécois plus pouvoir se sentir isolé
premier geste a été de fermer la salle
ici de fermer le bar est ensuite
d'instaurer la télédiffusion des dépôts
on vous savait qu'avec la télédiffusion
c'est beaucoup plus délicat pour un
député de ne pas être en excellente état
pour faire une intervention urgente la
fermeture du bo réussissent à le
modifier radicalement les climats au
chaud après la période des questions les
policiers passent par ce couloir juste
devant leurs atouts pour se rendre soit
vers l'édifice du premier ministre ou
encore dans leurs bureaux de députés sur
les étages une occasion à saisir pour
les journalistes et invités les
politiciens entre l intérieur pour leur
poser leurs questions
le norad tout m'est venue quand bien
c'est un terme anglais qui veut dire que
la salle dans la salle il va faire très
chaud
vous allez comprendre facilement
pourquoi les dimensions de la salle sont
assez modestes la salle est toujours
pleine de journalistes c'est assez
intense comme comme activité donc
ça veut dire n'est ce pas qu'un
politicien sur la sellette lorsqu'il
vient ici dans la salle
j'ai même vu à plusieurs occasions des
députés claquer la porte
là où j'ai des problèmes il faut que ça
s'arrête
c'est les amalgames les fausses
associations vous n'avez vous n'ayez pas
vécu cette émotion ou six chapitres la
population est en passe quelque chose
c'est ce qu'on va passer ce qu'on dit
quand vous découvrez la politique c'est
très important d'espoir d'avoir ce
contact
je dirais direct avec les policiers
cette salle au spread beaucoup
[Musique]